folks you know and I'm gonna fight to
protect a woman's right to make her own
personal issues but it gets through
health care i've also so for many years
and let me say this before you start to
clap or boo and is that for many years
as US senator i have i've supported the
hyde amendment like many many others
have because there was sufficient monies
and circumstances where women were able
to exercise that right women of color
poor women women are not able to have
access and there was it was not under
attack as it was that as it is now but
circumstances have changed
i've been working through the final
details of my health care plan like
others in this race and i've been
struggling with the problems that hide
now presents it's become clear to me
that to get universal coverage and to
provide for the full range of health
services women need which i plan to do
with the continued expansion to medicaid
and the public option of a of a medicare
of a medicare plan in that environment
where providers like Planned Parenthood
are under unrelenting attack where we
have a circumstance and I this is I want
to be clear why I'm taking a position I
have so I make no apologies in my last
position and I make no apologies what
I'm about to say the fact of the matter
is that when in fact there is this
enormous pressure and even threat to
close down clinics that are available in
the past for women who do not have the
funds but are able to have them paid for
privately as we've been able to do that
was one thing but we now see so many
Republican governors denying health care
to millions of the most poorest and most
vulnerable Americans by refusing even
Medicaid expansion I can't justify
leaving millions of women without access
to the care they need and the ability to
come to exercise their constitutionally
protected right if I believe health care
is the right as I do I can no longer
support an amendment
that makes that right dependent on
someone Zipcar and I want to be clear
with you I don't want to mislead you if
in fact if in fact he was still
available I think just says I've never
attempted to impose my views on anyone
elses that when life begins
I have never attempted to pose my view
on who should pay for it if people
fundamentally disagree with my with the
position we take but folks the folks
times have changed
I don't think these guys are going to
let up what's changed is and Jesse and I
talked about this in another context
when I was got the great honor of
receiving the the medal at the Martin
Luther King Museum and that was that I
don't think that most of us saw foresaw
I think Jessie did a little bit I didn't
that we would see a return of this
viciousness this is sort of this this
notion of pitting people against one
another that we are seeing now